in 10 days the must-see movie of the
year arrives spectacular I want to get a
closer look at this it'll break the rock
your world that's what heroes do
the revolution has begun the boldest
marble film yet I'm just a huge fan
Ragnarok rated pg-13 November third
hey hey we know each other
he's a friend from work everybody
thought you were dead
there's so much has happened since I
last saw you lost my hammer like
yesterday so that's still pretty fresh
no key no cloak he's alive you believe
it he's like he's up there I sense a
great change in your future destiny as
diet plans for you my friend
I have diet plans for destiny
I love the goddess of death is invaded
as job I thought you'd be glad to see me
and this dead
it'll be reborn my image
need a stopper here to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so putting together team
you'll date
[Music]
surprise this will be such fun
I
he's a fighter
I'm not a cream
and the goddess of death
[Music]
what were you the god of again
[Music]
you
you